[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's make way for the great vince
carter
who is the only player to have played in
four
different decades in the nba vince joins
us now on loan from uh
nbc sports covering the olympic
basketball games and the matchup that we
have
france against the united states let me
start with
luca and slovenia would that have been a
more interesting match-up
for team usa to watch than france
uh i mean i don't think so i think this
is going to be an interesting matchup
for
one reason and one reason only greg
popovich
coach team has not beaten his team they
lost to him
before uh prior to the olympics
uh and then they lost to him the first
match here so i think
it's a bad taste in their mouth you know
ever since
that loss in the days in between that
lost in
their next game versus iran they all
they heard about is
is papavi's the right coach is this the
right team did they have the right
nucleus of players when is kd going to
show up
well we saw kd show up we saw their
defense take off
and they're playing great basketball now
don't get me wrong i think
luca luca and his squad and
propellovic the guy who uh who got a
shot block at the end i think
that would have been a very interesting
matchup and obviously you know
what luca has done all tournament but i
think for
the us they wanted they wanted a piece
of france again to kind of get that
taste out of their mouths
what's the difference in how a game is
called in the olympics as opposed to the
nba
rules first and foremost i think you
look at a game and
for me as a former player
in the nba and of course have some uh
feedback experience
the physicality in the game you know you
can see him watching like man it's a
foul
with that deceiver you know if a lot of
things you're able
to get away with it and you know and
it's probably the first two games you
sit and watch and you're calling the
game in
the the ability or you're allowed to
knock the ball off the rim
that takes them them getting used to so
for nba players you can see the
hesitation they start to look at the
rest like wait
and now you know four or five games in
uh jason tatum knocked the ball off the
rim um
javale mcgee knocked the ball off the
rim once you get accustomed to it you
kind of adapt and that's what these
players are able to do they adapt you
know we have to remember
this team um like all the other teams
they only have three weeks
maybe a month to prepare and
come together as a squad to take on
teams like in australia who's been
together forever like
spain who's been together forever and
expect to win
so uh you know the task that that you
know these guys are dealt with
they've done a pretty darn good job and
you look at this team here
um there's three guys that came from the
finals
uh javale mcgee came in late uh kelvin
johnson came in late
uh zach levine had to wait because of
the covert protocol so
they didn't have their entire team when
they stepped
foot into japan because everybody was
all over the
world and finally get them back then
they get their full team back
1 30 a.m the night before the game
against france yeah why is ben simmons
not playing in the olympics
that's an interesting question i don't
know i think for ben timmons this is a
great opportunity i i kind of look at it
two ways i think it's a great
opportunity for him to get in the lab
and and just be in the gym by himself
and work on his game
get away from all of the noise and
continue to be him because he's a super
duper athlete
he he brings a lot to the table you know
i mean we always look at
uh we always nitpick and we pick one
thing about a player
oh he can't shoot the ball but you know
look at all the intangibles and other
things that he can't do
now on the other side of that at the
time well let me say this dad the timing
is kind of bad because if he had
some time if this was a normal season he
would have had a couple of weeks to kind
of
work on this game a little bit and then
you bring it to the olympics
and see and this is kind of your trial
run before the actual nba season you
know
you always can go back to the player
that you are but when you want to work
on something
it's a great opportunity to have live
real live basketball that counts
to work on your actual game see i just
thought he would
answer that question maybe confidence
though vince that he's playing with his
home country
it can be his team like this is what
he's he's missing i think he's lost his
like
his confidence and his identity this
maybe would have helped that and you get
to showcase your talents if you want out
of philadelphia
that's a good way to showcase your
talents to say hey this is what i can do
for you
i agree with you 100 you know and this
is kind of the mentality of some people
you know some people feel like hey you
know i'm not i'm not gonna
go out here and you know and give you
what you think you know i should do and
some people feel like they want to
you know stick to him so look at like a
giannis you know there's times when
giannis you know
you know it was said giannis that didn't
want to work out with
anyone he just wanted to work on his
game and i will show you who i am and
what i have
come this season time and maybe ben is
that way i mean this is kind of the time
uh i don't you know where there was a
lot of fire at
bin right now and this is a chance to
kind of get away from it
kind of refocus and go back at it
because think about this
at the same time yes i want to show you
but he still has to answer those
questions those questions still
going to come out now internationally
we're going to have to the questions
from the international folks who don't
get the opportunity to ask that question
all the time about
you know how things played out so
sometimes it's kind of good then to step
away from the game
kind of refocus recharge and come back
so i hope he's really going at it
because you really haven't heard much
from him or about him or what he's doing
in his game so that could be a good
thing
he's vince carter nbc olympics
basketball analyst and a
gold medalist a former slam dunk contest
winner
and uh spent 22 years in the nba
you know when you had the dunk over
frederick vice i didn't know who owns
that if you wanted to sell that nft
vince can you have you thought about
that
i think i have not uh i mean i've been
asked
but i think uh that is the the rights of
the uh the olympic um
committee or is it nbc i'm trying to get
you i know ben so i'm trying to get you
back i appreciate you
that's why you that's why you're legend
and you're the best and you're thinking
about others um
but i don't think i i lose that battle i
mean that will probably be a question
that i would ask down the line
uh as i learn more about the nft because
it's becoming a
obviously a hot commodity could you
reenact that with frederick vice
21 years later
maybe on a video game or i try to draw a
stick figure but
[Laughter]
i actually try to pull that off no way i
wonder i wonder vincent and you'll
obviously know this but it felt like
people then expected you after that to
do superhuman things
like like everything had to be a
highlight did you feel that that
you know after you you dunked on
frederick
i think well let me say this i
understood it i understood it i i knew i
mean and here's how i understood it
before games when i would work out
preparing for a game or you know getting
ready for a game warming up
to always asking for a dunk that's
duncan duncan duncan you know
i'm getting ready for a game you know
where i need to actually shoot the ball
sometimes
um so i i understood it and i wanted to
show that
i i was more than just that and i had
more to my game i just had to show pace
show my patience and and eventually you
know the rest of my game would shine
through
you know after i was like oh man i know
you're a good passer okay i didn't know
you could shoot the ball like that you
know it's
it's been there but i know what they
wanted to see
and you know if you think about it prior
to the olympics and that dunk
the dunk contest just happened in
february
and then the olympics rolls around right
after that so that all happened in
succession
it was kind of you know just added fuel
to the fire and
you know wanted to see more and just you
know whenever you step whenever i
stepped on the court
that's what they wanted to see he was
like yeah he hit a game-winning
three-pointer oh that's cool but who did
he dunk
i understood what that you know what it
was yeah we were waiting for a highlight
it was
like wait vince is shooting threes come
on that's not what we paid to see
yeah he's not driving to the paint now
why is he not aggressive
did you ever get dunked on where it was
like oh my god now i know what that
feels like
uh man this is a question i don't like
the answer
uh there is a there's a there's a guy in
the nba
um you probably can't figure it out um
he played for the minnesota
timberwolves he's currently in
cleveland okay
is that kevin love yes it is
it was kevin love kevin love
posterize you yeah everybody exactly
that's the reaction everybody says
uh for the few people that i've told you
know it's only me and you here so i
guess uh
you know everybody won't know about it
but what happened
is uh he got a bounce pass on the
facing the rim the right the the right
side of the block
i'm probably like at the elbow on on the
opposite side so let's say it's the left
side
and i tried to run and get there and he
like dropped steps two hands and
like i got my hands in front of him he
just dumped on me and he looked at me
and because we had some history he
looked at me he talked about like
a long ride after the game from the bus
to the airport i'm like
kevin love because when kevin love was
in high school
i gave him his player his gatorade
player of the year award
and the one thing one conversation he
had to me he said
you know i'm gonna be in the nba i'm you
know you know i'm gonna be in the nba
soon i said all right i'll see you there
he said all right
so i that's what i thought about when
that happened
because i'm like i gave this kid his
gatorade high school play of the year
award
he and maya moore that year yeah a few
years later
i get dunked on by him and i'm glad he
didn't throw it in my face
but it felt like he did i'm looking at
the video i'm looking at the video now
vince
are you yeah i i'm i'm looking at it
right now just pull
okay all right wow i mean that's uh
that's
one handed wow you know what he's
probably gonna capitalize and make that
an nft
and uh make a whole lot of money vince
he should because i guarantee a lot of
people
don't know about that play or you know
don't even like did he oh oh i
don't remember seeing this yeah good
what would you pay to get that off the
internet
um i gotta look at it again
no you don't play
i can say it it's a white guy that's
where that's why it's bad
well well that and you know the fact
that i remember it vividly
so yes it was bad
but as soon as you said i was like oh
gosh yeah kevin yeah
kevin love yeah you know it couldn't
have been like a high-flying guy
you know that dunks on everybody you
know had to be kevin love
uh well i'll say t-mac actually dumped
on me
but we're on the same team and i was
going for the rebound
and you know casually rebound offensive
rebound and he jumps higher
and he catches any dunks on me but i
actually got him back in the game as
well
um it's just weird saying that it's like
i got him back but we're on the same
team
so it's just like a friendly competition
but i remember that as well
it's great great to talk to you vince
hope you're doing well
and uh we appreciate your time as always
i appreciate you dan thanks for having
me that's vince carter that was fun